before we jump in this week you may
notice that I look a little different
the beard that I've been growing over
the last nine videos has suddenly become
a mustache why you ask
stick around to the end of the video and
I'll explain let's talk about meetup.com
and why you need it during your job
search
welcome back to another episode of
Udacity career tips my name is Martin
McGovern and it's a perfect day for
today's topic three reasons why you
should be using Meetup during your job
search if you don't know what meetup.com
is Wikipedia describes it as a service
used to organize online groups that
hosts in-person events for people with
similar interests
basically it is my favorite site to use
for networking during the job search
here are three reasons that I am
grateful for meetup comm number one they
are global and massive having recently
merged with we work so it is likely that
you can find a meet-up near you no
matter where you are in the world of
course with some exceptions second you
can filter by virtually any topic
allowing you to plug into discussions
that are important for your career
development including an entire section
devoted to career and business for all
you job seekers out there and third it
gives you access to like-minded people
in your area a lot of times when we're
starting a new career or making a big
transition we don't have a network and a
social structure that supports this new
interest that we've got and you are the
average of the five people you spend the
most time with so if you want to learn
about a new technology but don't know
who to talk to you just want to feel
less alone in your job search
meetup is filled with people who are
also looking to connect and chat about
these exact things as the tagline on
their website says do more of what you
love so let's get out there and connect
with some amazing people
quick pro tip if you really want to
maximize your meetup experience reach
out to the organizers of your favorite
meetup and offer to help them organizers
of meetups are often fairly strapped for
time and need a lot of help they need
help checking people in finding venues
reaching out to speakers all sorts of
different things and so if you really
want to meet the right people and build
the best connections it's good to get
involved
as we wrap up today's video it's time to
talk about the mustache why do I have it
for the past seven years every November
I have grown a mustache in support of
charity the Movember foundation raises
funds to deliver innovative breakthrough
research for prostate cancer testicular
cancer men's health and suicide
prevention the mustache raises awareness
awareness raises money the money
supports the programs and the programs
save lives
check out Movember calm if you want to
learn more gross stash of your own or
donate to a good cause
thank you so much for watching click the
link in the description below to see
other Udacity career resources that will
help you in your search and put any
other questions you have in the comments
and we'll be creating more videos for
you in the weeks to come I appreciate
your time and wish you the best of luck
in your job search